[Musica]
che cosa vogliamo veramente nella nostra
vita qual è la cosa più importante
essere felici e da dove partiamo per
costruire la felicità partiamo
dall'infanzia per questo parliamo di
educazione
l'educazione È un'opportunità di
crescita e di cambiamento per
l'individuo e per la società è una
risorsa per se stessi e per la
collettività
è quel terreno fertile in cui trova vita
l'identità alla libertà e la vita
l'educazione vive della bellezza di
ciascuno di noi all'interno di un
contesto molteplice di aspetti culturali
linguistici sociali
la mission dell'educazione è proprio
portare la felicità Perché una persona
felice può cambiare la sua vita e
raggiungere tutti i suoi obiettivi ma
tante persone felici cambiano il mondo
io a un certo punto nel mio percorso di
vita personale e professionale ho
incontrato il concetto di Ig questa
parola danese
difficile da tradurre Mi piace pensare
che IQ sia un po' quello stato che ti fa
sentire
in pace con il mondo anche se i gay in
realtà è molto più di questo
pensiamo che per tradurre la parola IG
in italiano nella nostra lingua dobbiamo
utilizzare per forza tantissime parole
cura benessere
intimità relazione condivisione
gratitudine sono veramente tante e
ancora non basta sicuramente
IG conosce una grande fama a livello
mondiale ce ne stiamo interessando un
po' tutti e questo ci fa riflettere
perché perché
siamo tutti alla ricerca di una sorta di
ricetta della felicità perché ne abbiamo
bisogno
abbiamo bisogno di felicità quindi nella
nostra scala di valori Portiamo la
felicità al primo posto il problema è
che molto spesso non sappiamo come fare
Io ho scelto di portare la felicità nel
mondo dell'infanzia nell'educazione e
quindi di portare questa arte dello
stare bene e come lo facciamo Beh Prima
di tutto
riprendendoci i tempi della quotidianità
che sono importantissimi per la prima
infanzia Ma il problema che ci dovremmo
ricordare tutti anche da adulti parlo
delle routine quei momenti della
giornata che si ripresentano in maniera
costante
caratterizzati da benessere cura
intimità dobbiamo riportare l'attenzione
sul qui ed ora
e lasciar perdere quelle consuetudini
del quel famoso si è sempre fatto così
e quindi come facciamo a tradurre in
educazione il concetto Ig
è molto complesso Ci sono tantissimi
Aspetti Oggi vi voglio parlare del
concetto di fiducia
abbiamo fiducia nei bambini
nell'infanzia Sì abbiamo fiducia
nell'infanzia ma abbiamo fiducia
nell'infanzia Se lasciamo i bambini
liberi di giocare con una certa dose di
rischio avete sentito bene rischio
l'Italia in realtà è un paese ricco di
regole che disciplinano qualsiasi
aspetto Figuratevi per la prima infanzia
quindi tende a ridurre al minimo il
concetto di rischio il nome della salute
della sicurezza Avete presente quella
sensazione quando
nasce un bebè e improvvisamente nelle
case si sigilla tutto quindi chiudiamo
con quei quelle chiusure plastificate
Ogni tanto ogni cassetto Questo è un
eccesso di sicurezza
i genitori hanno paura del rischio
perché lo identificano con pericolo
quindi una pedagogia del rischio viene
vista come
all'antitesi rispetto all'educazione
della cura dell'accudimento che era
tipica dell'inizio del Novecento
e invece il rischio è importante il
rischio fa parte della vita non è solo
qualcosa di importante per la prima
infanzia il rischio c'è sempre in
qualsiasi momento
fa parte del lavoro lo insegniamo no E
allora anche i bambini hanno diritto a
delle esperienze che siano concrete e
reali usare il coltello per tagliare
usare un martello per costruire
arrampicarsi sugli alberi usare i piatti
di porcellana e bicchieri di vetro non i
bicchieri di plastica
questo è importante perché il tatto è un
senso assolutamente fondamentale per
conoscere
Virginia satir una psicoterapeuta
statunitense ci dice che abbiamo bisogno
di quattro abbracci al giorno per
sopravvivere
8 abbracci per mantenerci in buona
salute
e 12 abbracci per crescere quindi
l'importanza del tatto della tattilità
quindi vietato non toccare dobbiamo
toccare le cose
e qui arriva un altro concetto
importante che è sbagliare è ok dobbiamo
sbagliare Lasciamo i bambini liberi di
sbagliare di sperimentare perché
l'errore È un grande maestro il
fallimento ne parliamo sempre anche del
fallimento noi adulti Ma poi magari non
permettiamo il bambino di sbagliare
e questo sembra banale ma poi nella
quotidianità succede così e i bambini
sono degli oggetti di cristallo che
mettiamo all'interno di una vetrina
perché Diciamoci la verità meglio se non
sbagliano i genitori preferiscono
prevenire gli errori gli insegnanti
correggerli e quindi abbiamo uno Stai
attento Non farlo non toccare faccio io
che tu non sei capace
Allora oggi ci lasciamo con un buon
proposito
ed è questo una piccola vademecum che
possiamo utilizzare a casa sul lavoro in
qualsiasi tipo di contesto
sono dei piccoli principi IG per tutti
saluta e sii gentile fai smorfie sorridi
ridi dai e ricevi un abbraccio Esci il
più possibile gioca liberamente Muoviti
riposa quando sei stanco mantieni
l'ordine e sì grato
[Applauso]